lots to see at pax prime of course and
we've got a new game just announced
their first look at it here live on our
stage show well I mean you maybe have
looked at it a little bit over the
weekend but joining me is our Dan and
will from the behemoth guys big weekend
for you huh oh yeah it's been great you
know we are in Velen Game four
which I do want to say is a temporary
name a temperature for that brand name
but it's Alien Hominid Castle Crashers
battleblock theatre game for exactly but
you guys released this sort of
announcement trailer and if anyone you
have ever been to pax you know the
behemoth you guys are always a big
presence at PAX people like walking
around with your plushies you guys are
on lanyard so you got tons of place but
stations that are always full of people
playing your games so pretty special for
you guys to be showing off the game for
here at PAX yes a lot of fun and for
anybody wondering what we're calling it
is a fast-paced turn-based co-op
adventure game no it's okay it's got a
lot to it fast-paced turn-based co-op
adventure game all right well let's
we're gonna dive right in and get a look
at the intro to you folks we're gonna
take a look at the intro sequence we're
gonna let you hear the voiceover and all
its glory done by that by the way this
man will right over here yeah that's you
I find myself wondering what the world
must have been like before the bear
crashed into our frail planet
transforming all we once noon to a
colorful kaleidoscope of delicious spare
sand I love it the world was more
hospitable no doubt more orderly more
sensibly sickening because it sounded
boring and I hate being bored I can't
imagine a world without the bear or the
storms yes beautiful waves of emerald
blood cried out from the heaviness
promising death in lawless disarray
constantly upsetting the order I get
butterflies in my tummy just thinking
about yes speaking of way
the old stamper in action alright so
here we are starting off yeah in the
middle of one of the storms yeah this is
Horatio the blueberry farmer and his
he's gonna bout to experience some of
the chaos that all the barracks space
bear blood is creating one thing I want
to show off is the simple please bear
blood raining down causing all sorts of
chaos I love it it's mixing space and
time as we know it and Horatio is having
to deal with some of that so one thing
that's really big on the game here is
the movement system it's mechanically
very simple you can see as you move the
cursor around you can see your potential
path you hit a and then you hold down Y
and execute your turn love them hexes so
a lot of its really streamlined we'll
get to that in a second this is our
first hard counter in the game so heavy
shields are really good at blocking
arrows most arrows not all they'll still
get through you got some not it won't
block all the arrows so are you is the
player then tapping a button here or is
there it's sort of oh no defensive
status he's not doing he's not doing
anything yeah it's just reject enemies
to take their turn right so now the same
thing movement he says let's go here and
Horatio automatically decides well I got
a sword I might as well use it yeah so
we're trying to streamline it's more of
a game of positioning than it is
choosing an ability and then a target
and all that it's essentially like chess
you want to think of it that way as
opposed to getting next to a guy and
then pausing the game with your
equipment menu and then having to go
through and I think I'll put this okay
let's get back to the fight now you know
you might have seen right there Horatio
he went between two guys right there
that are bordering him yep and you don't
know which one he's gonna hit because he
can now potentially choose between two
guys so if you want to choose your
target you want to get to their flank
and you can focus fire on units that way
multiple guy you know we just lost this
show options oh my god oh yeah yeah I
was looking up for him for a second
there but probably not for long this as
we could tell from the opening intro
right like a happy world wonderful place
I know it's a horrible place to live
well if you were to take all time and
space as we knew it and put it in one
spot
I think there'd be a lot of stuff that
wasn't it'd be a little bit that could
be a little messy and there would be
space bear blood yeah so we're getting a
look at our world map here for the first
time and so you can look around and then
you can just move wherever you need to
go thankfully it's very well marked in
the beginning Horacio is just trying to
take cover he's he's out in the bear
rain that's a terrible idea
so he's just trying to get somewhere and
look it's his shelter we all know what
happened that and we got another
cinematic right here you shared your
berries how generous of you she
requested Horatio's aid you see her
castle was raided by grumpy warriors and
she doesn't like that very much
get on my little hero perhaps this could
become a mutually beneficial
relationship there ameed pipistrelle ax
who's talking that guy that's the scary
I know it's you but like who are you in
this game
the the narrator or is this my own you
know remain you'll find that out later
yeah that's that's not clear to us yet
he really loves the chaos though he's
really into this for some reason he
definitely is so pipistrelle ax
she's got different stuff than Horatio
she got a heavy mallet and a light sort
so that heavy mallet is a big deal here
we can see it's gonna bash the heck out
of helmets and helmets are our defense
in the game whereas Horatio sword not
going to do so good but there's some
archers off to the right there and so
we're gonna keep Horatio closer to the
archers so he draws their fire and
pipistrelle is gonna smash the heck out
of that helmet
and you might see that she's making gold
while she does that to making gold what
are you gonna do with gold when the
world has turned to horrible bear reign
chaos if I mean something
people still pay for stuff when the
world is undone I guess yeah five
currency you know it's the
post-apocalyptic capitalism yeah you
know here I mean you know Horacio could
use a hat as much as that mustache is
wonderful oh yeah and that's actually
something a little bit will show you you
can customize characters and things like
that so these guys aren't totally tied
in we'll show you that a little bit
later all right
I really do like pipistrelle is adorable
little shield yeah it doesn't do that
much but you know sometimes it does
every little bit helps I guess they're
tiny buckler's yeah I didn't even notice
that her entire army is that you can see
them all dead on the ground there that's
because they used swords so just a bad
idea against helmets unfortunately they
didn't know that and Horatio's in a bit
of a tight spot if she hadn't hadn't
hadn't run into her so you're
controlling both characters here right
you can move both of your characters and
forelock think it'll take the same turn
they didn't move at the same time that
your turn will play out yeah yeah
they'll head out and do their thing the
neat thing about this game is there's
counter-attacks there's criticals
there's misses there's dodges there's
all kinds of stuff that you just can't
be prepared for and you got to just work
with the chaos yeah every match ends up
different and you're even talking about
I mean even with the positioning you
know if you're next to two enemies
there's uncertainty about which one
you're gonna attack you know you might
prefer to strike one over the other but
let's I guess Horatio is gonna do what
Horatio is gonna do yeah you never know
like for instance here's a space shuttle
so space and times all messed up they're
misusing a space shuttle as their
getaway vehicle because it's just it was
there it was it I guess you gotta make
do with it was there and the keys were
technician yeah so we're gonna head up
to the city here because we still have
to take cover the castle is not in a
very good shape when you are taking
cover you want the cover to not be on
fire is like a general tactical yeah I
definitely want work that unless you're
immune to fire in which case it's not so
bad case you're all good there's some
zombies there's some cupcakes there's
robots there's all kinds of stuff
they're all everything from timing space
is here so there's some yeah you can see
oh look at that
and then so we've made it to the city
and it's got a little prompt there it
says if you're lost press B let's try it
so we can show off our what we call our
breadcrumb system yeah so if the world
maps huge and if you get lost you can
leave yourself a little trail of
breadcrumbs that's poop breadcrumbs you
know breadcrumbs get something on the
ground right now yeah but if you were
lost in a forest and you left
breadcrumbs on the ground do you think
they'd stay there very long you know yes
it's true we've thought of everything
like to eat bread crumbs less like to
eat poop
I would imagine yeah so there's probably
something that lets you poop in this
world yeah that could be true we don't
we haven't seen it yet so Horatio and
pipistrelle oh they make some gold and
so they've gone to the arena but they
need a third fighter and conveniently
this half Cyclops was outside he says do
you want to join souls let's say no cuz
that's weird that's intense and he's
well so he's trying to please us try to
attend to no let's say no more beard
than mo ha I guess he had okay so let's
join souls with the half Cyclops ooh I
mean nothing could go wrong right I mean
so let's get in there and just get some
gold
this place is what's bumping by the way
yeah oh yeah the city you know even
though it's going down like that he's
still got a good spirit but still like
their bloodsport
oh yeah you know they they don't know
any difference they don't leave the
walls so here we see yo slips in a bad
spot murasia says oh maybe I should be
up there to soak up that fire and we can
see Yosef is able to throw his axes and
as a chain
to stun he can get in there in melee
it's just not as good an idea for him so
what we're gonna do is put Horacio in
front of Yosef and have Youssef throw
access from the back line and hopefully
stun that guy with use ease because
because he's a jerk
cuz Uzi there it is perfect brings OG an
evil battle fight so we were able to
focus fire a unit just because he missed
he made a misstep so there's a there are
ways to you know all go for one guy
there mm-hmm and and it's all about
picking it your targets and seeing who's
weak we can see pipistrelle and she
still hates elements so she's gonna go
after the guy with the helmet oh so she
has sort of a if she gives if she's
given the choice between two strike able
enemies will she go for helmet generally
no we just Aaron Aaron who's driving the
back does decided he's gonna go for
what's strategically sound you can
totally make the wrong decisions oh yeah
you know we'd love to let you guys make
all the wrong decisions we allow you to
do that very nice that's part of the
part of the process okay so you do have
to choose targets you know for the melee
units you choose the target by walking
next to it and for the range unit you
get to pick a target specifically yeah
so this there's a whole system where as
you're moving that a around yeah the
target reticles will light up on who's a
potential target so you can move Yosef
around and see can we do that for a
second Aaron can we show ya yeah so see
how okay the same thing for Yosef if
he's in range you'll see oh he can
strike that guy guys now I'm seeing a
lot of numbers pop up as the arrows are
coming in and these heroes are talking
like a champ but I'm all but they're not
seeing any health bars on screen or
anything like that you you will okay
alright and you will that's Whirley days
here I can I'll actually I can go into
there right now actually so Yosef is us
as part of Cyclops Laura and cyclopses
can see the future because they traded
one of their eyes to the gods but all
they could see is when they were gonna
die Yosef just knows how dead he is and
you join souls with him and you just
made that official by killing Egypt and
like killing things in the arena yeah so
now you can get it too
oh my next fight so that's that's why
you can see that sounds like you should
try to get more soul mates we just made
a bunch of gear from our fight oh well
now after we choose who's gonna be our
hero and all of them are on okay choice
they just hit harder and they have more
health
you can pick anybody you want the
Emperor gives us a house because we
fought so awesomely Wow and in the house
this is where the game starts to really
open up this is where you can see a lot
of the potential along the bottom you
can see there's four more slots down
there we only have three guys right now
uh-huh
and you can see Aaron Aaron's
customizing his guys you can say you
know what I want pimp Estrela to be
something else you can do that or you
can just be like you know I want the
banana what mallet instead of the
regular mallet well of course you guys
would have weird weapons I love it the
large-- nanner yeah and so you can just
I mean you can pretty much do whatever
you want with the gear that you find so
we just gave you kind of the baseline of
how it works and then you're allowed to
do any kind of strategy you want and
there's other creatures in the game let
you saw some of the cupcakes on the
zombie oh you can put those on your team
if you get some oh really yeah mix it
well yeah yeah you can mix mess all you
want so the Emperor says oh you know I
gave you a house you owe me you got to
take care of these guys I hope by the
peach indentured and those are first
quests so the quest system itches yeah
yeah yeah totally you can fill the wagon
with stuff and all that but we'll get
into that a little bit later on but
there's the bear yeah there is our
nipples and you see you know the arrow
I'll tell you where to go on your quest
and you can just even fight that guy
that's actually what a full Cyclops
looks like but he's got a helmet on you
can't see as I wrapped a big Cyclops
i quick question this is very important
logistically the breadcrumbs that you
leave when you are in a caravan is it
the poops of the beasts pulling the
caravan or the poops of the people
inside yeah so the beasts in the caravan
infinitely poop okay yeah
excellent develop ooping in the caravan
the beasts are leaving it on the ground
their supplement yeah they're keeping it
in something you can see down there the
hut you can see the health how far they
move there's the purple bar the purple
bar has experience so as every time you
are to hit someone on a turn you gain
some experience and if you get that last
hit of that guy you get a big bonus
leveling up in this game will heal you
it's the only way to heal in a fight
aside from a unit that heals right other
units but the priestess comes like a
cupcake the cupcake heals other units
for instance but these guys have to rely
on their own experience just when they
level up they're gonna fully heal so you
can have a guy soak up a bunch of damage
and then have him level up like it meant
nothing and it's all good and he's
stronger so see I mean the way you're
talking about it seems like it's not
just gonna be something that comes along
as a nice bonus during combat and you're
like oh great I'm glad that happened but
something you would actively strategize
yeah yeah your weak player laying that
last an entire match back and have one
guy left and take out the whole team of
people if you level up at that right
you're chaining the levels together it
gets really interesting there's some
very interesting mechanics and just how
fundamentally different this is where if
you have low level characters you have
an advantage in certain ways that
they're going to be able to heal during
the fight whereas a super high level guy
is not going to have as much of a chance
to level well not nearly as much
actually and he'll be you know beefier
and all that but if you if you want to
rely on that kind of thing
I mean lower level guys so you got to
keep getting new guys and stuff yeah
there's no way to the only way to like
restrict your own leveling would be to
not get to maybe not get the killing
blow as often right so maybe it behooves
you didn't do that yeah so I mean are
you gonna tower level someone on your
team and let them keep getting the last
hit however you want to like shape it is
it's all up to you I mean you could
bring all mallets you could bring all
those there's a lot of hard counters in
the game so that might be really bad if
you do that but you're welcome to try
out any
and then you said before you're welcome
to make bad decisions you can do it yeah
and you can learn you know if you lose a
character it's okay because they'll come
back in normal difficulty yeah come back
to this work we do plan on having an
insane difficulty but we haven't quite
worked out what that is lots of people
are suggesting permadeath I don't know
sure that could be scary really supposed
to be scary yeah it's scary it's deaf
yeah
so we're almost we've almost got these
guys I'm feeling pretty good about that
so I do want to mention to you that
there is co-op so the way co-op would
work is you would have your set of guys
and I have my set of guys okay and we
would take all our moves and then we
would both say I'm ready at you're ready
and then they all blew it would move out
and then all red would go and so it's
very similar to the same kind of pace
that we're doing here now would it scale
up being the encounters like is the coop
you could be playing this map co-op or
you could be playing it solo it's just
sort of seamless with the yeah yeah the
game will will balance based on how many
guys you have it doesn't necessarily
mean more guys although normally it does
huh they might be a little more powerful
just because otherwise there's no
challenge yeah so yeah the game does
scale based on you know how many people
you have and all that and of course your
progress in you know we play a little
bit co-op then I'm gonna go play a
little bit solo my progress is
continuous across all yes you keep your
same guys when you cross in the
multiplayer or not there's advantages in
co-op you know you you have more guys
that can cover you and and you can bring
stuff that you've never been able to
bring alone because if you want to bring
all cupcakes that's not gonna work if
you're alone right you get what I can't
report unity or I can have like I'm
gonna have a couple of these in a couple
of that and and we could bring way more
Giants if we're both together than if we
were alone and things like I see and
here's our fourth companion she has no
idea what's going on she didn't know
that while she was trying to find the
new world that all space and time got
screwed up she was out in the ocean so
she's like oh cool I'm
made it acclaimed the land you want to
be my guides and you agree because well
you know why not
I guess so so that seems cool and this
is unfortunately where our demo ends we
do have a video that sort of
encapsulated it pretty short so it's not
gonna tack on the end here I'd love the
tack that on the let's do that let's
watch that right here you'll find
yourself in the city maybe with a friend
maybe inside your precious little house
customizing your team's looks and
strategies then it's off to pop to the
market to purchase out of them dainty
dresses for all your warriors so they
look pretty as little peaches as they
prance from epic quest to epic quest
meeting new hero getting stronger maybe
getting a little too because it's
alright we'll just doing this kind of
voice over again a little maniacal with
it do you ever have giver come out of a
session and your co-workers are looking
at you a little differently like dark
places everybody know it's expected by
this point they know you have you know
him you know we've been working him for
years
it's great because you know I'll just
give him a bullet point hey we need to
convey this and then he just writes it
all does it all I never know what I'm
gonna get very cool
all right Dan will thank you guys so
much for coming off get enough awesome
first look at Game four from the
behemoth
I just watched one and steam in case you
missed it Xbox one and steam you guys
have a general timeline no release date
however we have held on to this game
longer than we usually hang on to our
games there's true so usually you know
Castle Crashers show up like four months
in this is been in development about
twice or maybe a little bit longer than
that
alright you don't have to wait as long I
think because we waited longer to show
it excellent well I'm sure a lot of
people looking forward to getting their
hands on it thank you guys so much I
haven't
Shadid enjoy the rest of your packs